so this program is very very ambitious
and that it's trying to answer one of
the big questions of our time what is
intelligence and how learning can
contribute to it it starts from the
hypothesis that there may be a few
simple principles like the laws of
physics which could explain human
intelligence animal intelligence but
also allow us to build intelligent
machines and so we're trying to sort of
figure out some new techniques that
would allow machines to learn very large
amount of background knowledge about the
world about how the world works by
observation a little bit like like
babies and young animals and that will
take AI to the next step so this
research is has very long term goals but
is already having incredible impact in
society today so when you hear the terms
a I and D planning it's in large part
due to the progress we've made in this
group so that's one of the things that
we want to develop in the NMD program
you know figure out if the brain uses
any kind of learning mechanisms that are
similar to the ones that we think are
for machines and vice versa of course
get inspiration from what we learn about
other brain works for more machines so
see far has been an incredible social
environment for the group of people
behind this program so we bring people
you know in small workshops we bring
students and in summer schools and it
seems like this to kind of build a
vocabulary a way to think about things
to exchange ideas very early before you
know you would publish a paper so CFR
has had a crucial role in fostering
those interactions that accelerate
progress
[Music]
you